uh rishi sanae thank you very much for
being on the show and talking to me the
day after your spring statement look the
big headline of it obviously was that
living standards are going to fall to
their lowest level in over six decades
let's just take that in since the 1950s
but millions of people will have been
watching your statement they're reading
the headlines
and they're very stressed and they're
very anxious are you
yeah i'm i'm anxious on their behalf and
i know that it's the number one concern
that people have right now families are
struggling with the rising cost of lots
of things and that's why in the spring
statement i wanted to make sure that we
demonstrated we're on people's side and
we
announced the tax plan that will deliver
the biggest
net cut taxes and that cut to personal
taxes in two years
well in quarter of a century taken
together but i guess taking a step back
i've always tried to be honest with
people i can't you know i can't protect
them from absolutely everything that we
face but where we can make a difference
we will and i'm confident that the plan
yesterday will be you you actually
during covert judged the public mood
very well and you did come in behind
people
you're not really doing that now
really i mean
what you've just talked to me about
is in this unprecedented moment of
inflation at a full decade high
living standards fall into the lowest
levels in this year since the 1950s it
is unprecedented and you haven't really
been able to respond
in a way that perhaps people need
is that because you just simply cannot
do that or do you acknowledge that you
might have misjudged the moment that
people feel abandoned well i think that
i think the right thing to remember is
the context and they're very different
situations what we're grappling with
over the last couple years was a
pandemic where the government forcibly
shut down the country and the economy
that's different to dealing with global
inflationary forces which we're not
alone in facing you know the us actually
seeing higher inflation than we are
right now europe similar and the
response to different economic
situations is necessarily different and
and actually i think what we've done is
substantial if you take together you
know nine billion pounds to help people
with energy bills announced last month
the significant tax cuts that we
announced yesterday they will all help
but of course they can't mitigate
or the difficulties that high inflation
is is causing no chancellor could do
that it's like bringing a pea shooter to
a gunfight isn't it i mean the level of
support is only scratching the surface
of the actual reality of people's lives
you do acknowledge that i you can make
an argument about you're limited in what
you can do but at least acknowledge
that the pain people are going to feel
is real and that as a government you
cannot really
offset it oh gosh i've been completely
honest about that and i've always said
that you know no government can fully
offset the impact of inflation running
at those levels that's the same here as
it is in in any other country you're
absolutely right and i haven't shied
away from being honest with people about
that you know we it is impossible to
fully protect people against some of
these things and of course our actions
to sanction putin as i said yesterday
and as of others they're not cost free
for us here at home i'm going to bring
you to two specifics which i wanted to
ask you about one was on energy bills it
seems to me that you are going to have
to put in additional support in the
coming months do you accept that that is
likely
so we don't know what's going to happen
in october it's really too early to know
what will happen then and the energy
prices are moving around so wildly that
i don't want people to sit here right
now and think gosh it's going up by this
much or we're not going up we don't know
uh the forecast move around by the day
you held you held money back you held
money that you could use back it seemed
to me yesterday in order to give you a
cushion to make more interventions is
that fair well i think in general i've
always been responsive to the situation
and it will continue to be responsive to
the situation do you acknowledge about
the absolute poverty figures and doesn't
that bother you the idea that under your
leadership
half a million children are going to go
into absolute poverty it's the biggest
figure according to the resolution
foundation outside a recession well i i
mean what we do know is a track record
because there's lots of projections and
speculation about the future but the
track record shows that over the last uh
10 years since we've had conservative
governments in charge the number of
people living in poverty has actually
declined by about 1.3 million people
that includes 300 000 children from
memory so actually that's a record that
i'm proud of now obviously a lot of that
happened before um you know i was i was
imposed but the actions i've taken over
the past couple of years have ensured
that we have protected those on the
lowest incomes the most i understand you
can say about the problems of the
economy and inflation of things out of
your control about global inflation but
to kind of deny the fact that
think tanks that look at this stuff warn
about
inflationary pressure putting people
into poverty
uh and and sort of challenging that i
find it's like being a bit gaslighted to
be honest
i'm not denying for one second that
inflation is difficult of course it's
difficult and it's most difficult for
those of you my point is you could have
given more support to low incomes and
you chose to target tax and that's your
decision as chancellor but just
acknowledge that you chose to target
your tax cuts in a different way i
actually chose to target them
specifically in a way that is beneficial
for those on low and middle incomes and
actually you quoted lots of think tanks
they also said that the best way to help
those on low incomes through the tax
system is to raise national insurance
thresholds it is the policy that
delivers the most benefit i do want to
ask you a little bit
about you and your values and picking up
on your values your parents
emigrated here in the 1960s from east
africa your father a gp your mother a
pharmacist they opened a chemist and
then they sent you
to one of the best public boarding
schools in the country to winchester and
now you are the chancellor
they were very ambitious for you clearly
you know i'm sitting here talking to you
the product of
lots of people's sacrifice hard work and
kindness and start my grandparents
actually who emigrated together with my
my parents and and you're actually right
about my parents for them education is
everything they thought that was the
best way they could help provide a
better life for me and my younger
brother and sister so for them that was
the focus of their hard work uh was to
provide that opportunity for us and
that's ultimately what motivates me
today it's why i'm in politics it's why
i do this job it's to try and spread uh
the say you know as much of the
opportunities that i was really
fortunate to enjoy to as many people as
possible and education for me is is one
of the best ways we can do that as a as
a country i wonder what it must have
been like for you going from a
from the background you had into the
upper middle classes
of of british society go into this
public school this one of the best in
the country where you met so many people
from the upper echelons of society what
was that comfortable or was it tough for
yours it's something in between
you know it was an amazing opportunity
uh is what it was did you feel like you
were out of place no i mean i you know i
i was really lucky to have that
opportunity it was it was something that
was really extraordinary it certainly
put my life on a different trajectory as
i said it's you know part of the reason
i'm sitting here and i'm really grateful
to have had that opportunity and you
know i look back on that time it's
helped make me who i am as a person and
i'm sure it helps me do the job in the
way that i do it and it confirms to me
that education is one of the best
tools at our disposal in politics to
spread opportunity and that's true and
that's and that's actually just
something that you know the values that
i was brought up with and now we can
have a chance to make sure in practice
we implement i i also have asked because
i just wondered did you feel did you
feel out of place did it feel like a
world you didn't belong in or did you
just adapt
well i probably probably just adapted
because i'm i'm sitting here talking to
you so yeah you probably did okay it's
you know but i i think you know i think
we have an amazing country that is
brilliant at integrating people from
lots of different backgrounds uh into
society and that's that's a very special
thing about our country it's always been
an open tolerant welcoming country and i
think if people are if people are
prepared to work hard and integrate then
they're always been warmly accepted and
that's that's what i've always found but
you do have talked about racism
and feeling very stung
by that so it wasn't always an opening
and there were points in your life oh
gosh of course of course there were yes
and of course i experienced that growing
up and i think actually
you know now that when i think about
what's happened to the country i think i
said it at the same time i think some of
the things that i experienced as a kid
growing up probably you you would much
more
unlikely to see now and that's a sign of
the progress that we that we've made as
a kind of with your girls do you worry
about it for them about them experience
racism will you think the country no
sorry
in a way that i bet my parents probably
did worry about it a bit yeah um not
that i've talked to them explicitly
about it i i don't worry about it for my
girls and that probably tells you a sign
of that that's a good process that we've
made
and we have always been
there's always improvement of course
there's always room for improvement it'd
be wrong to pretend that there isn't uh
but i i generally feel really proud of
the way that our country does this i
think it does it i think it does it
better than most and i've got two more
things to ask you uh just on your your
background um
so you were very successful you are very
successful you went to oxford then you
went into the city you worked in finance
and a hedge fund you yourself became you
were self-made millionaire you became a
millionaire you then married a
multi-millionaire one of the wealthiest
women in britain
whose father's a billionaire
you kind of it struck me that you went
from being sort of part of the upper
middle classes of britain to almost
being part of a global elite how did
that affect your outlook on life
well i think actually the the experience
i've had of living and working abroad
and particularly i spent i studied in
california and silicon valley you still
have a home there don't you yeah then i
still and i've worked there for many
years and as my kids were born there and
that's actually been really helpful
because i think one thing that
policymakers and people in my job need
to do is to have a global outlook you
know that we need to make sure that
britain can compete absolutely so that's
really good in terms of global outlook
and business and and
looking also at silicon valley how do
you keep
how do you keep it real
yeah you're really wealthy man how do
you keep it real do you take a bus
do you go to the supermarket of course i
go to the supermarket and i you know
whether it's there's lots in north
allerton where we live in in north
yorkshire and t-side is on my you know
my back door so if i step forward like
if my kids are we're at the cinema at
the weekend we're in darlington we're in
stockton we're at the you know we're at
the clip and climb there those are the
kind of things that i'm doing on the
rare chances i have some time off with
my uh with my kids and you can see that
in the policies we've put in place right
you know as a northern chancellor i want
to make sure that
people feel the benefits of leveling up
everywhere you know i made a decision to
put the new treasury office in
darlington we've created a free port in
t side which is bringing jobs and
investment to the area and again because
of my constituents because of that
perspective like like all mps i'm not
alone in that it's a wonderful thing
about our system is that being good
constituency mps means that we are very
responsive to what's going on on the
ground in a way that by the way most
other finance ministers around the world
don't doesn't have that kid in a way
that i'm even asking you this question
that because you're wealthy somehow you
might not be in touch do you find that
does that great with you a bit i know
it's entirely expected in in this job so
you know it's perfectly reasonable
question for people to ask i've i just
one more thing you've gone from head boy
you're a head boy weren't you
to hedge fund
to chancellor you're pretty successful
you've always been at the top of your
game it seems to me and it always looks
quite effortless as well although i'm
sure it's not
um
what's the one thing that you've got
really badly wrong in your life
oh gosh i think we've only got about 10
seconds left haven't we so there's a
long long list of things but no i mean
look the thing that is hardest for me is
balancing like everyone is like juggling
your
profession your personal life is
juggling your career and your family and
it's trying to be you know i want to be
the best possible person i can in this
job because a lot of people are counting
on me to do a really good job and that's
a big responsibility there's a lot of
challenges and at the same time i'm
still a dad and i'm still a husband and
being
good in those roles is also really
important to me and you know candidly
it's a constant struggle so you used to
get feel like you don't see the girls
enough so that is probably the the
biggest thing that i do what's your
biggest setback though what's the have
you ever had a setback i've had i've had
i've had plenty everyone everyone is at
plenty on a daily basis
i'm confronted with the fact that i
can't ever in this job do all the things
that people would like me to do and i
have to deal with that every single day
i have to every single day know that god
i can't solve all the problems that
people want me to no matter how many
hours and i'm prepared to put in quite a
lot and no matter how many i put in
right i can't solve all those problems i
can't you know protect everybody against
everything that is coming their way and
of course i have to go to bed every
night knowing that and during the crisis
i was worried that we'd have millions
and millions of people without a job and
because of the actions that we took that
thankfully didn't happen but you know
things like that happen all the time
that's what i'm grappling with day in
day out stressful job
once when boris johnson
was asked about his leadership ambitions
he said if the ball came loose from the
back of the scrum which it won't of
course it would be a great great thing
to have a cracker tip is that your
position too well actually pm is more
rugby fan i'm much more cricket than uh
football fans so i you know i don't know
what the appropriate analogy is but look
as we talked about at the moment there's
a lot going on there's a big job to do
and i'm fully focused on doing that job
and trying to do it as well as i can but
if that cricket ball came at you would
you catch it at this point i'm just
trying to you know stay at the crease
and keep them keep keep in place and
i'll get out if the football was at your
foot would you try and score a goal i
don't
actually i've managed to do more cricket
nets than i've played football in the
last year so it's my one bit of
relaxation now then going do the odd
cricket net okay wish you so nice thank
you very very nice thanks for having me
thank you